concluyó la cumbre de líderes del mundo
que durante dos días aquí en glasgow se
reunieron para tratar de encontrar la
hoja de ruta adoptar medidas para evitar
que siga aumentando el calentamiento del
planeta para tener controlada la
temperatura justamente a 1.5 y también
reducir emisiones el primer ministro
británico que es el país encargado de la
cob 26 ha dicho que está optimista pero
cauteloso sobre el progreso de esta con
26 y advirtió que hay mucho que hacer
pero lo cierto es que esta segunda
jornada ha sido bien importante porque
ha dejado dos grandes anuncios el
primero el acuerdo de más de 100 países
para erradicar la deforestación en el
año 2030 en el que también están en este
acuerdo y es bien importante resaltar lo
la china y brasil brasil recordemos por
la más unidad es considerado el gran
pulmón del mundo y también este acuerdo
incluye recursos importantes para
mantener los bosques del planeta
todo el mundo por supuesto también se
acordó en un pacto similar que más de 80
países acordaron recordar recortar el 30
por ciento del uso del metano que es un
gas un 80 por ciento más contaminante
que el propio co2 de hecho se considera
que este metano ha contribuido en un 25
por ciento más al calentamiento del
planeta